have you picked up a VR headset yet well
one of your options just got cheaper I'm
Tony this is a GameSpot news update and
be sure to subscribe to keep up with all
the changing costs of virtual reality
effective today the oculus rift headset
and touch controllers will be bundled
together at a lower price of six hundred
dollars that's what the headset used to
cost just by itself if you already have
the headset you'll be able to grab the
controllers for a hundred bucks
but the bundle will likely be the only
option going forward oculus VP of
content Jason Rubin talked to GameSpot
about this saying that price is one of
two things the company needs to do to
push the rift forward the other being
new content oculus has been in the news
recently for some pretty heavy legal
reasons but Rubin isn't worried that the
lawsuit will affect business for more VR
talk check out our debut episode of
reboot which takes a deep dive into
Resident Evil 7 and for all the
videogame pricing news you're already in
the right place
you